i wouldn't wish it upon anyone to do the
job that i do
um it can be very difficult things can
break and
crises can happen and that can happen
with any company
but when it happens to us you know we're
not just talking about an
email browser not working or like a
project management software not loading
we're talking about a
you know person who's just gone through
the most traumatic moment of their life
not being able to access resources
so i think the stakes are a lot higher
and i think i didn't realize that when i
first started the company is how
high the stakes are welcome to 20-minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be meeting an entrepreneur that
is channeling her own personal traumatic
experience
into a company that is going to help a
lot of people meet
madison campbell the ceo of leta health
madison is a trailblazer and sexual
assault advocate
after going to college to study
epidemiology and space populations
madison has become a well-seasoned
entrepreneur she led a company prior to
lead the health called
lyanno which was a software development
shop based in lagos nigeria
today she is working hard to promote the
autonomy and self-actualization of the
sexual assault survivors through lita
health
by developing and providing resources to
help them overcome their difficult
trauma madison campbell welcome to 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm doing amazing i mean as amazing as i
possibly could on a monday
um but um thank you so much for having
me
no no thank you for coming here and you
know right before we we we started this
recording i mentioned to you that you
know one of my goals through the show is
to
understand better why people are doing
what they're doing and what with what
conviction do they come into the
companies they're building and obviously
here
uh it's going to be a i think a really
inspiring
way for me to understand better the the
conviction that people are coming with
you're a young sexual assault advocate
and survivor and
today you're running leda health
previously the me too kits
but also i'm i'm curious to hear both
you know your personal journey but but
also understand better
you know the gaps in what's happening
today we're in 2021
we seem to be resolving a lot of the
issues that we've been seeing over the
last hundreds of years
but i think that you you're describing
here an issue that is
has been unspoken about for a long long
time and i'm excited to
join to learn more about it from you so
madison tell me a little bit about
your own journey and how leda health
came about yeah
so you know i think there's a lot of
founding journeys um
and you know for me mine started in a
very highly
personal space of actually experiencing
trauma myself and i believe that a lot
of our
you know other folks in our company have
experienced trauma whether it is sexual
trauma or other trauma
i think everyone experiences trauma in
their life and i think
everyone kind of has a decision that
they can make which is
am i going to take this trauma and is it
going to impact me and i'm not going to
be able to move forward with it
or am i going to be able to take it in
and create something better because of
it
um and so with that being said you know
i decided to take
my trauma and turn it into a company
which is one way
of you know dealing with it probably a
better way would have been therapy but
i decided to you know build a company
around that
and you know really examine the issue of
sexual assault
um to start off with because it is
something that is highly personable to
me
but you know in examining sexual assault
i think
where i've really come and and what i've
really been looking at is just the
problems plaguing
you know young folks right college folks
and sexual assault unfortunately is
you know humongous problem that i don't
believe we've uh
tackled quite yet um but you know that
doesn't mean that we can't eventually
expand into other problems which are
very very difficult
to tackle and that are sometimes very
scary to talk about
right and so what what do we know you
know in
at least or in the united states of the
world what do we know about sexual
assault today
you know thinking about the problem
space you know as as a market it's
obviously not a market but
but thinking about it it is a market
what is going on
i mean it it you can actually it's
totally fine to say it's a market right
because
you know when one in four women will be
sexually assaulted during their four
years in college
uh one in four yeah one in four so you
have a 25
chance um you know during during your
college years of being sexually
assaulted i
i believe that's a market um you know
and that's just
in those college years one in five women
during their lifetime will be sexually
assaulted
i believe the statistic for men is one
in six
um you know amongst a very very high
percentage of folks that are in
um you know by pogba or lgbtq
communities
and even the transgender community which
sees a huge amount of sexual assault um
happen
um i you know it's astounding how much
um you know really occurs and you know a
lot of that is under the age of 25
right and so that's something that is
impacting you you know kind of as a
young person that you know for the rest
of your life you kind of have to say
you know what am i doing moving forward
how is this going to impact me
um how is this going to impact future
relationships um
and even confidence in the workspace
right
right and so leader health i want to
fast forward a little bit i'm going to
do a little bit of
ping pong here to try and understand you
know the founding
the funding journey here what what does
leader health do today
so right now we're a holistic platform
for everything after the sexual assault
so um as much as you know we want to
kind of eventually be in prevention
you know the first thing that we kind of
examined is um getting support after
sexual assault can be very difficult and
it can often feel
like you know you can't trust anybody
you don't know who to trust you don't
know what resources are out there
and so lita is really building a company
around everything
like i said after the assault so
starting with at home evidence
collection kits
but going into mental health and medical
care as well
whether that's offering free suv testing
or free plan b
um basically anything after a sexual
assault we're here for you
um and you know we want to be that
community when you feel like no one else
really understands what you're going
through
right and so now going back a little bit
the founding of leader health you're you
started with them with the me too kids
right
and can you tell me a little bit about
your decision
to start a company in the space what was
it immediately after you
you went through the you know the event
or was it
you know did this come after after a lot
of thought yeah i mean
it definitely wasn't like i was sexually
assaulted then i woke up the next day
saying
a perfect business opportunity but it
was
you know years of um really examining
the trauma that i had gone through but
not
just my trauma in examining um you know
friends of mine's trauma and
understanding that what happened to me
was not a unique experience it was
something that happened to
a lot of other folks you know their
stories oftentimes were worse than the
story that i went through
and you know the one thing that all came
together
in those stories was you know they felt
like there was a lack of resources and
they felt like there was a lack of
community
and even though there are very you know
traditional resources out there
sometimes schools can offer resources
and sometimes nonprofits can offer
resources
i was astounded by you know the here
lack of all the survivors that i
met not wanting to access those
resources for privacy concerns
um or not wanting to access them because
they couldn't access them in the company
their own home via telehouse
right um and so that's kind of what made
me
want to you know build a company around
that um i think most founders want to
look at a problem statement
um and once they see that problem
statement you know try to
build things that can hopefully help
that
right and so what was that experience
like actually starting a company in the
space
you know what is the reaction that
you're getting how are you bringing
people on board
what is the vibe like with the team as
you're working on such a meaningful
problem
i mean i think the team that we have now
we've had lots of people that have come
in and out of lena
whether it's for three months or two
years um we've been around for like two
years now
um i i think the vibe of the folks that
we work with are
you know generally people that every
single day they want to wake up
and they want to talk about this problem
and they want to you know move the
needle forward
even if it's just you know a very very
small amount
um so i'm i'm really lucky to work with
so many people
that every day they wake up and say you
know enough is not enough we can
actually move the needle
up forward in a really meaningful life
and you're when you're starting this
company the reactions of people around
you
yeah i mean i think from survivors we've
always had
you know really positive reactions
because survivors understand
you know what it's like to be sexually
assaulted and what it's like to try to
access resources and not be able to
and you know we've not always had the
best responses
from every single party
um you know mostly it comes out you know
from a
you know concerned perspective for
survivors and i understand that
um but you know the one thing that i
consider my north star is building
something that
puts survivors first um and not
necessarily the institutions which have
historically um
kind of been created to undermine
survivors and their wishes
i i see and so two years going strong
what have you learned
about this not industry but the space
in this line in these past two years i
mean i wouldn't i wouldn't maybe things
that surprised you that you didn't
realize before
i wouldn't wish it upon anyone to do the
job that i do
um it can be very difficult um i think
any
any founder can you know have a very
difficult you know
day-to-day life but i i think the things
that i
noticed is just you know the tiredness
of it all maybe i'm saying that because
it's a monday and i'm already tired but
it can be a lot right um things can
break and
crises can happen and that can happen
with any company
but when it happens to us you know we're
not just talking about an email browser
not working
or like a project management software
not loading we're talking about a
you know person who's just gone through
the most dramatic moment of their life
not being able to access resources
so i think the stakes are a lot higher
and i think i didn't realize that when i
first started the company is how
high the stakes are and i think that was
something that i realized
in building the company and working with
my team members
it's just to understand that how you
know big a mistake
um you know we can make an impact in
such a a crazy way versus any other
company
and how did you grow you know whether
personally professionally
leadership through this experience of
channeling you know your personal trauma
into something that is going to be
helping potentially millions of people
around the world
i think the biggest thing that i've
learned is you know to never just stop
with what you initially thought was
possible
you know when we talk about how we went
from me to kids to lita health and what
we'll eventually
expand to i think in the very beginning
i thought it was only so big what i
could build i think you know
i could only tackle this very small
problem and i think in
you know continuously building the
company i realized that
no you know if you build enough amazing
people behind you
who have the expertise you can build
something huge that not only will just
you know tackle sexual assault and
you know we'll tackle make your make
your societal and cultural
um health care problems
right and so now if you're looking at
sexual assault in the united states or
the world what what are some things that
could really move the needle that you're
saying wow like the the
you know there's so much low hanging
fruit here that that we need to be that
we need to fix that i can't believe it's
not actually happening um
i think when i started the company i
thought what would move the needle
forward
is reported so i thought if more people
reported
um then that would move the needle on
the conversation but after two years of
doing this work
i realized that reporting wasn't
actually what moves the needle forward
on this
you know on the subject i think what
moves the needle forward is
you know trying to understand what
justice means and why
um every single secular assault survivor
is going to view justice in a completely
different way
um because i think right now uh
interesting yeah i think the industry in
general
believes that justice oftentimes can
only be achieved through
the penal corrective system of which
we've learned from
you know countless healing circle groups
so support groups um with secular self
survivors
that um you know the penal corrective
system is not what a lot of survivors
want all they want is accountability
um you know they want accountability
they want someone to say that they're
sorry they want someone to say
hey what i did was wrong and in fact
that i'm going to do better um
and i think that those are the things
that you know will actually move the
forward is more accountability
um from those folks that have you know
caused harm but not necessarily saying
that that accountability has to come
through the penal corrective system
right and by the way in terms of in
terms of trend are we
doing better as a society are we doing
worse as a society
um i mean statistically speaking the
stats haven't moved from like one and
four one and five
or you know 77 unreported or 90
unreported on colleges so you know i
would say that we're
we haven't really moved the needle yet
but you know as
a as a culture i think where we're
getting better at talking about it
i think the metoo movement did a lot of
work in terms of
you know bringing the conversation to
the table i don't think that was enough
i think there's a lot more work that
needs to be done um
and i i'm really looking forward to
lita kind of being at the forefront of a
lot of those discussions on how do we
continue to move the
you know forward and not just from the
conversations that happened back in 2017
and 2018.
right and that makes a lot of sense and
you know if you're thinking now
about a lot of people that are going
through different traumatic events
and you know you you we started the
conversation with you
mentioning how there's different ways of
approaching it you can decide to go to
therapy you can decide to close in
you can decide to go and try and try and
try to do something
outward what what how are if you'll have
to look back and
and talk to yourself whether it's after
the traumatic event or
or when you're thinking of how to deal
with it what what advice would you give
your sort of younger self in retrospect
i think um i would have first told
myself to
um if it wasn't me keeping the evidence
of what had happened that night giving
someone else
that evidence so if in years to come i
wanted to look back on it i could have i
think
something that i regret every single day
is you know having deleted
photos having deleted text messages um
because it was it was too traumatic for
me to deal with um
and i wish that i would have given that
to somebody uh so they could hold it on
for safekeeping
so even five ten years later i could
have you know kind of
looked at that and started that healing
process but i think the other thing that
i would have wanted to tell my younger
self
is uh you know it wasn't your fault
which i think is the first thing that
you start to think about after
um insult or any traumatic event is that
i cause this
um and i think that that can be very
harmful
is to you know constantly as a society
tell ourselves that it is our fault for
the way that we were treated um when in
fact it it wasn't our fault
and so that i think has been like the
biggest learning um
you know of myself and like a lot of
other of our team members as well is
that it wasn't our fault
um you know what had happened to us and
i think that's a really big
you know thing to consider
right and so you know tangibly you know
people go through these experiences
it's not always clear that they're able
to sit down and and reflect and say okay
how can i you know make the most of the
situation
and then go help other people so what
what did you do that worked for you
as you are trying to very also
objectively think
through how can i actually go and make a
positive impact even though this is a
subject that is so
you know that that is so personal to me
i i think
just because i've decided to you know
devote a lot of my life towards making a
positive impact for my trauma i think
it's also very important
you know to talk about the fact that it
it doesn't have to define you what had
happened to you
and so you know every single day i tell
my story about my sexual assault
you know five to ten times a day that
doesn't have to be a reality for every
survivor and they don't have to turn
that trauma into a business or turn it
into volunteering or doing anything
um but you know i i think it was
something that i needed to do as a
personal healing mechanism for me and as
you know what i wanted to see as justice
and i think this goes back to
you know what how do we really move the
needle forward and i think it's you know
coming to that realization of what does
justice mean for you
and just because justice meant you know
for me starting this company doesn't
mean that that's going to mean bad for
every survivor probably not many
survivors
um and just realizing that you know
trying to find that north star and come
to the realization of what do i need to
move on and what do i need to begin
healing
is incredibly important
wonderful madison i really want to thank
you for coming and for
sharing with me you know your insights
and your journey i have just
three short questions a little bit about
you
and i want to take you back to your
childhood and
what what really fascinated you while
you were a kid whether it was a subject
in school or a passion
what fascinated you really um so i was
really
into entertainment so i thought i wanted
to be a
dancer or a singer or an actress or
you know something in entertainment that
was my passion
um and every single day i i even went to
a conservatory whenever i was like 15
um i went to a performing arts high
school so that was something that was
you know i've been really passionate
since the age of five
and i think it's actually really good
for business i highly recommend to
folks um the best thing that they could
possibly do is take an improv class
because you know you're going to be in
meetings with investors where they're
going to ask you questions on the fly
and they might be very difficult
questions um and you're going to have to
figure out how to respond to those and i
think
you know being an improv and being able
to understand
people's emotions how to feed off of
those emotions and answer questions even
when you're stressed
um and under pressure um with you know
the you know proverbial stage lights on
you where you have to perform i think is
an incredibly good skill that i learned
amazing and and where do you drive
inspiration from today
um i think my team
so i think the most important thing that
you can possibly do
is build a team that every single day
they inspire you to wake up and continue
doing
um the work that you're doing and as
much as you know
myself and my co-founder inspire each
other to wake up every day
and keep fighting this problem i think
it's my team who have all experienced
trauma
who can see it working and can see us
moving the needle that inspire me even
on days where
i feel tired and i don't want to get out
of bed to know that there
is you know folks basically waiting
right to be inspired by me and to be led
by me
to continue building what we're building
definitely and three words that you
would use to describe yourself
um sarcastic um
um ambitious and
i'll i'll use the word that i feel right
now which is tired
so i think ambition and tired can go
together because highly ambitious people
can still
you know be tired at what you know in
in the middle of the day even though
they've been pushing all morning so
definitely madison thank you very very
much i really appreciate you taking the
time to come and share your journey
and best of luck with leaderhealth and
stay safe thank you so much thank you so
much for having me
you